[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
make way for brady quinn fox sports
college and nfl studio and game analyst
and of course the radio host on fox
sports radio two pros and a cup of joe
with lavar arrington and jonas knox the
show that precedes hours on fox sports
radio let me start with that brady what
do you make of that vote coming up in
december
and the likelihood that we might not
have a 12 team playoff until 2025.
i'm keeping my fingers crossed and
praying to the college football gods
that we do expand um i i think the
college football playoff
has had a ton of momentum and we've
gotten to a point now where
we've seen there's flaws in the process
of the 13-person committee picking
the four teams to play off for it um
there's just it's an unlevel comparison
between conferences between schedules
and those
and the likes so i think we've gotten to
a point now where
expansion brings intrigue
back to college football in the playoff
again it allows brands like cincinnati
who i don't know if they'll end up
making in the top four this year or not
we can have a debate all we want about
whether or not they're deserving um but
it allows them then the chance
to actually make it into a playoff and
let's see what they can do and let's see
if they can make a run but i think
greater than that damn
it it really allows
more parity in college football right
now what you're seeing when you see a
five-star four-star recruit and you
listen to these commitments a lot of
times they're saying i want to go to
alabama because i want a chance at going
and winning the sec and winning a
national championship you know a lot of
kids are saying that when they go to
some of the top schools ohio state
alabama uh georgia oklahoma you're
hearing them say this
and the problem is is those guys aren't
looking someplace closer to home because
they feel like there's just no shot of
going to play in the playoff you expand
this to 12 teams i think not exactly
like march madness but you get a team
like gonzaga that was once viewed as a
cinderella story that's now viewed as a
powerhouse and it might take some time
to build it to that but i think it'll
help build that narrative for some of
those programs and create more parody so
um you know could it get done in a
couple weeks i hope so it's not that
complicated we made so many adjustments
over last year with covet why not and
you already had a 12 uh team or playoff
proposal that you know was being worked
on for two years by jack swarbrick the
athletic director of notre dame and a
few other conference commissioners so it
shouldn't be that hard to put it
together it just really comes down to
the alignment where these games are
played and how they go about structuring
i think the first round of that 12 team
playoff
what's your reaction to this proposed uh
10-year contract for 90 million dollars
for mel tucker at michigan state
um
and you got the game against ohio state
this weekend where they're 19 point
underdogs
you've beaten michigan twice
but he's only coached
what 29 games 28 games and now you're
gonna put him up on par with uh nick
saban with what he makes at alabama what
am i missing here
uh well did you ever see that movie the
perfect storm with george clooney um i
did but i honestly can't remember how it
ends i don't think it ends well no no it
doesn't work out well
maybe maybe that's the case here too
because i think this week at ohio state
may end up giving michigan state the
business and by the way probably even
penn state after that like they could go
on a two-game skit after announcing this
but it really was the perfect storm when
you think about the track record of mel
tucker remember he up and left colorado
after one year and so he's already shown
the propensity to do something like that
even though he's only been in michigan
state now for two years so that was
probably a concern you have all these
big programs now lsu in particular that
i think we both know
is the one that was probably throwing
out some big figures or big numbers at
him trying to lure him back to the sec
where he once was a defensive
coordinator so that plays into the
structure of the contract and the value
but you then have you know a program
that has kind of turned some things
around and so i think they're trying to
build off this momentum they're trying
to build off this intrigue into the
program and he's able to strike on it
when he's one of the most wanted man
probably not only in college football i
wouldn't be shocked if there's not a few
nfl teams given his nfl pedigree in the
past that didn't look in on it so
when you give him a deal like this
he's basically saying like i'm staying
put
you know i don't you don't have to worry
about coming back to me next year the
next year the next year if there's a job
opening
i'm staying put here at michigan state
it looks like a lot of money but i do
think if you as you project forward all
these coaches contracts are only going
to go up with a big 10
tv rights deal coming up soon i think
schools are going to look at other
revenue models as well like like
professional sports with gambling to
figure out how to capitalize on some of
that too so it always seems like a lot
now i think five years down the road
though you'll see a lot more coaches who
are up in the stratosphere as far as
what he's been compensated yeah they're
gonna go in and say i want the mill
tucker deal
hey what what what are you uh looking
for uh mel tucker money is what i'm i'm
looking at and how is lane kiffin
possibly up for
the job or be interested or whatever
it's rumored
reported that lane kiffin is on the
short list to take over at at the u
what do you i mean he spent some time in
south florida you know not not too far
away up in fau uh and so i think he
understands how to recruit that area
whether it's back from his ties in
alabama or or even usc when he was
probably recruiting more nationally
and so i think it makes sense from that
standpoint
you know they've got to figure out their
athletic director first um i would think
that'd be your first move before you go
hiring
your head football coach and they are
they already have manny diaz there still
so
uh that's you know it gets a little bit
tough to talk about when there's already
somebody who's in that position right
now but give layne credit for what he's
done i don't care if it's fau who he
built up like my wife and i used to go
up to the boca bowl which fau would play
in up there um you know every you know
december and we go grab a burger at
shake shack we go watch football games
and
the transition from what was before to
what happened after with lane kiffin was
dramatic it was unlike anything i've
ever seen at a smaller school and and
what he's done at ole miss bringing them
back to be competitive relevant they're
talked about within the sec you know
miami's looking for that i mean florida
state miami played this past week and
dan did anyone talk about it did anyone
care outside the state of florida no i
mean that's it's sad because i grew up
and i was like this was the match up
like the ohio state mission and all
these other great rivalries that was one
that you circled because you knew how
good both programs were they've both
taken a dip in a decline i think miami
is desperate to get back to where they
need to be and lane can bring that sort
of buzz and this climate in college
football in 2021 back to the u in my
opinion oh i look i i know lane kiffin
can do it and he he makes you relevant
he has fun
um he's laughed at himself
but i never want to hear a coach
complain about the transfer portal ever
again
you know you got these guys leaving
after one year two years
you know it i just don't just say the
words here
let these kids if they want to come and
go because if they go to play for a
coach
then
they should have that opportunity to go
and play for another coach that they
want to play for now they finally have
i i think where coaches complain about
the transfer portal is when other teams
are trying to poach players on your
current team that aren't playing yeah
that's that's where this thing gets
tricky and this is how it works it's
actually pretty simple they basically
have a kid on their roster contact who
maybe was a high school teammate or or
played against him in high school they
contact that player social media attacks
what have you and they start the
conversation usually through his high
school coach
and they're like hey he's not playing
he's pretty unhappy can you hit him up
you know tell us what you think and
that's kind of the grassroots of what's
going on behind the scenes so when you
hear coaches complain about the transfer
portal it's more because in some cases
they're making decisions
in game that have to do with other teams
trying to poach the guys already on
their roster that maybe are sitting
behind a guy who's going to go to the
nfl next year
and and they don't want to be patient
enough to wait they don't want to wait
on that opportunity and so i think
that's where more the frustration comes
from is
having to recruit
having to recruit transfers jucos you
know obviously incoming freshmen to your
program but also the guys on your own
roster because especially at talented
schools everyone's trying to poach them
he's brady quinn fox sports college and
nfl studio analyst the uh big noon
kickoff on fox in norman it's oklahoma
and oh uh iowa state um
give me the trap game this weekend the
one you go uh oh is there one that
stands out for you
um
you could have said that about this game
i think for oklahoma had they won last
week just with oklahoma state you know
there for them next week in bedlam
that was one that kind of i was thinking
of going into it um i i don't know i
mean obviously for michigan i think
that's the one you're looking at they're
playing maryland and they've got ohio
state on the other side
and you know michigan needs to win out
they need a little bit of help but
that's the one that you know they can't
really look past maryland i don't think
maryland's a threat
but in reality you know they like to
throw the football around a little bit
rakeem jarrett's one of the better wide
receivers in college football and you
never know if you get caught looking
ahead or a sleepy environment there in
maryland and maybe you don't play the
game you need to i mean it's not like
michigan's offense is the most prolific
they've run the football effectively
kate mcnamara has continued to improve
throwing the football downfield uh in
particular last week and and a nice
comeback win but the truth of the matter
is they're not ohio state and so they
can't afford to get behind any team in
my opinion uh otherwise they kind of run
that risk of potentially falling short
so what about maybe you look at michigan
like that utah against oregon
it's not a trap
because i i think it's a trap game in
the sense of like oregon can't afford to
lose and still make the playoffs but you
know really no matter who wins they're
still going to see each other in the
pac-12 championship game
so that's that's the crazy thing about
this matchup is oregon can't afford to
lose it
utah probably still can and the irony to
it too is the way they go about picking
the rose bowl which is out of you know
out of the rotation for the semi-final
games utah has a better chance of losing
this week and going to the rose bowl
than if they happen to beat oregon and
then they go on and play each other in
the pac-12 championship game and lose
that game
because oregon's not getting the
playoffs so they would probably be the
team that ends up going to rose bowl so
it's a weird scenario but i don't even
know if that's a trap game i just think
it's a tough game to play in salt lake
versus a good utah team that's really
come around with cameron rising at
quarterback for them
is it fair to compare mac jones's rookie
season to tom brady's
well no i mean tom didn't play his
rookie year right well his first year
playing
uh no i mean the nfl is at such a
different point now too i think when you
look at the style of offense and
you know i remember you know charlie
white's coaching for two years that was
his offensive coordinator when tom first
you know took over
and they had a great defense they ran
the football well they mixed in some
screens and then downfield shots they
didn't ask him to do a ton
mac jones is being asked to do a good
amount within the system the way they
spread things out they're asking to be
very accurate on time with the football
understanding where he needs to go with
the football i mean josh mcdaniels
really requires that from you within his
system
but also i think it's just the lack of
them being able to really create big
time explosive plays at least stretching
the field vertically so it's a part of
what they have but it's also a part in
the product of how the games play now
it's just more spread out so i think you
look at the efficiency you look at
everything from mac jones and it's
incredibly impressive
but it's hard not to think that you know
maybe tom brady would be able to do the
same thing but you know mac jones is a
more developed player
um than i think tom brady was at that
point he was battling with drew henson
to get into that spot they weren't
throwing the football around quite as
much i mean mack at least had a year to
start and obviously the replacement duty
to two or two years ago and i think that
prepared him well for what joshua
daniels has asked him to do right now
and i always bring this up with people
when they talk about quarterback's
development uh you know dak prescott
great quarterback mack jones great
quarterback we're not quite sure about
justin fields or trailer and i said it
has to do with the environment you go to
especially early you want early success
for a quarterback
you know mahomes goes to a team that was
12 and four
andy reid offensive minded guy i got
kelsey i got tyreek hill
okay you're going to succeed dak goes to
the best offensive line in football at
the time he's got a 1500 yard rushing
uh running back
he
if if he goes to jacksonville dak
prescott is not on anybody's radar you
know even mahomes would be a curiosity
but he would still be like oh yeah that
guy's you know entertaining it's
that's success and you know this as well
as anybody you go to a team
and it's not a good situation whether
it's head coach offensive coordinator
owner
all of the above
and it's hard to succeed
with that
but you know you faced it
yeah situation and circumstance is
paramount so i think any player's
success you know we talk about it with
first round quarterbacks because
you know that's you know that we have
the most impact on the game we're the
face of the franchise and that's really
where you build all the hype for the
draft for but i don't care what player
you're talking about and what system
they're in um you know kendrick bourne
was looked at the wide receiver for the
new england patriots as maybe at best
the third option in san francisco a
special teams player you know now he's
contributing in a much bigger way within
that system because the position that
bill belichick and josh mcdaniels in
particular are putting him in so
you know you put trevor lawrence on the
new england patriots i think he's doing
the same thing mack jones is doing you
know maybe justin fields too
i think with the rest of this
quarterback class different story and
that's not to take away from what mack
jones has done it's just mac jones
entered into the best possible scenario
for him his skill set and what he's
being asked to do and i think there's
probably one or two other quarterbacks
in his draft class that would have been
able to excel to a degree if they were
drafted to new england but that's
obviously not the circumstance
i wish blank would have drafted me
oh man
now now we're going down a slippery
slope because i feel like um you know
any team i i say it's gonna i'll be
spurring the browns and that was my
childhood team i rooted for growing up
i mean well you go back and you look at
like the good teams you know like we
played against in our division
pittsburgh or or baltimore and baltimore
is the one that i was talking to at the
time during the draft
and they had that great defense they had
a running game
and you know you would have walked into
that not having to necessarily do a ton
and so i didn't get drafted there wasn't
me ended up being joe flacco the next
year and he was able to kind of work his
way in through that system to eventually
go into super bowl so
baltimore is always the first one that
comes to mind because
they're the one that i was talking to
the entire 20-second pick of the draft
back in 2007 trying to get to know them
because they were going to take me at
23. so that was always the one i always
kind of say man i wonder how different
things would have been had i got drafted
to baltimore as opposed to cleveland
you'd be playing for the jets this
weekend against the miami dolphins
that's right
because life comes full circle
at some point playing for the jets
having to go up against the dolphins
that blitz heavy defense i think
i think you did okay okay i think it
worked out okay for you i mean who knows
that i wouldn't be here with you you
know and then we couldn't be a part of
you know the uh joe flacco would be
there joe flacco would be talking to me
right now
you'll be talking to me a different
story
have fun in norman always great to talk
to you brady thank you buddy we'll talk
to you next week
thanks for having me it should be fun
that's brady quinn uh big noon kickoff
on fox they're going to be in norman
oklahoma iowa state against number 13
oklahoma